[Musique]
mais
et plus efficace à la sortie de
l'hémicycle du département
le syndicat des broderies de cilaos
offre au président un masque un objet
qui fait partie d'un grand dispositif
voté le 29 avril en commission
permanente
l'anticipation de la reprise d'activité
c'est le plan basque on voit bien qu'il
ya des initiatives un peu diverses qui
viennent des territoires pour produire
des masques tissus et bien il faut
coordonner cette production il faut
avoir de la lisibilité et nous
département à travers leur plan masse on
est capable d'apporter des contributions
des communes parfois qui en auront
besoin
[Musique]
coordonner et impulser sont les maîtres
mots de l'action du département ainsi à
la cellule défi développement des
filières innovantes toute la chaîne de
production s'est adapté adaptation des
marrons même le service des filles
s'appellent développement des filières
économiques innovantes donc on est en
plein dans l'innovation menacé d'une
couture avec mathieu aux commandes de
deux ans qu'on a réfléchi
qu'est ce que pourrait proposer de
répondre à la demande qui est anticipé
la reprise des agents on est passé au
stade 2 on nous a demandé de d'équiper
tous les clichés qui ressort du public
du conseil départemental pour les
protéger même le côté barrière dans les
passations de papier ou demande
administratif donc on avait réalisé le
petit produit qui est derrière la
banquette mejia est ample et si on en a
dû livrer 50 pour 50 accueille
éparpillés dans l'île
la plupart des agents sont en contrat
d'insertion
et voilà un autre défi 300 bénéficiaires
du rsa et une trentaine d'encadrants
sont recrutés pour répondre à la demande
un rsa volontaire qui permet une aide
forfaitaire journalière de restauration
ou encore de transport les structures
bénéficieront elles d'une aide à
l'équipement
les valaisans nous avons cette actualité
or 2 argent et aussi une production semi
industriel coordonné par le département
un objectif répéter aux médias car ces
masques de protection a prélevé
confinement seront essentielles pour
protéger les publics vulnérables
les agents du département mais aussi
pour relancer notre territoire
[Musique]